and we actually did some work like that
um modeling hyenas who were trying to
steal a kill from lions which happens in
africa i mean hyenas are
quite intelligent but not really
intelligent and
they they have this behavior that's
more complex than anything else they do
they can band together if there's
about 30 of them or so they can
coordinate their effort
so that they push the lions away from a
kill even though the lions are so strong
that they could
kill a lion kill a hyena by by striking
with a paw
but when they work together and
precisely time this attack
the lions will leave and they get the
kill and
probably there are some
states like emotions that the hyenas go
through the first they
uh they call for reinforcements they
really want that kill but there's not
enough for them so they vocalize and
and there's more people more people more
hyenas that come around
and then they have two emotions they're
very afraid of the lion
so they want to stay away but they also
have a strong affiliation
between each other and then this is the
balance of the two emotions and
also yes they also want the kill so it's
both repelled and attractive and then
but then this
affiliation eventually is so strong that
when they move they move together they
act as a unit
and they they can uh perform that
function so there's an interesting
behavior that seems to depend on these
emotions strongly and makes it possible
um important actions and i think
a critical aspect of that
the way you're describing is emotion
there is a mechanism
of social communication of a social
interaction
maybe that maybe humans won't even be
that intelligent or most things we think
of as intelligent wouldn't be that
intelligent without
the social component of interaction
maybe most
much of our intelligence is essentially
in our growth
of social interaction and maybe for the
creation of intelligent agents we have
to be creating
yes fundamentally social systems yes i i
strongly believe that's true
and uh yes the uh communication is
multifaceted i mean
they they vocalize and call for friends
but they also
rub against each other and they push and
they do all kinds of
gestures and so on so they known act
alone and i don't think people act alone
uh
very much either at least normal most of
the time
and social systems are so strong for
humans
that i think we build everything on top
of these kind of structures and
one interesting theory around that
bigotness theory for instance for
language but language origins is
that where did language come from uh and
and it's a plausible theory that first
came social systems that
you have different roles in a society um
and then those roles are exchangeable
that you know i scratch
your back you scratch my back you can
exchange roles
and once you have the brain structures
that allow you to understand actions in
terms of roles that can be changed
that's the basis for language for
grammar and now you can start
using symbols to refer to uh objects in
the world
and you have this flexible structure so
there's a social structure
that's fundamental fundamental for
language to develop
now again then you have language you can
you can refer to things that are not
here
right now and that allows you to then
build all the
all the good stuff about planning for
instance and
building things and so on so yeah i
think that very strongly
humans are social and that gives us
ability
um to structure the world but also as a
society we can do so much more because
we don't
one person does not have to do
everything you can have different roles
and together achieve a lot more and
that's also something we see in
computational simulations today i mean
we have multi-agent systems that
can perform tasks this fascinating
demonstration
marco dorico i think it was um these
robots little robots that had to
navigate through an environment and
there were
there were things that are dangerous
like maybe a
a big chasm or some kind of groove a
hole
and they could not get across it but if
they grab each other with their gripper
they formed a robot that was much longer
on the team
and this way they could get across that
yeah so this is a great example of
how together we can achieve things we
couldn't otherwise like the hyenas
you know alone they couldn't but as a
team they could uh and i think humans do
that all the time we're really good at
that
yeah and the way you described the
system of hyenas
it almost sounds algorithmic like the
the problem with humans is they're so
complex
it's hard to think of them as algorithms
but with hyenas
there's a it's simple enough to where it
feels like
um at least hopeful that it's possible
to create
computational systems that mimic that
yeah that's exactly why why we looked at
that
as opposed to humans um like i said they
are intelligent but they are not quite
as intelligent
intelligent as say baboons which would
learn a lot and would be much more
flexible that hyenas
are relatively rigid in what they can do
and therefore you could look at this
behavior like this is a breakthrough in
evolution about to happen
yes that they've discovered something
about social structures communication
about cooperation and and it might then
spill over to other things too
yeah in thousands of years in the future
yeah
i think the problem with baboons and
humans is probably too much is going on
inside the head
we won't be able to measure it if we're
observing the system with hyenas it's
probably
easier to observe the actual
decision-making
and the various motivations that are
involved
yeah they are visible and we can even um
quantify possibly their emotional state
because
they leave droppings behind and there
are chemicals there that can be
associated with
neurotransmitters and we can separate
what emotions they might have
experienced in the last 24 hours yeah
you